[Music]
kappa
outdated pog champ overrated
long have we waited now we debated
we have been duped get played
suckers there is a reason why people
absolutely
love spamming debated in twitch chat if
a player pulls off
a successful bait it can win them the
game
right there and then in today's video
you're gonna see
just how far people will actually go to
take home the dub
with the top 10 debated moments in
esports
starting off at number 10 we have the
roshan bait
this bait is regarded as one of the most
innovative dota plays of
all time no one has ever done that no
one has
ever done that in the history of dota
after a game 1 loss no tidehunter needed
a creative way to turn the tides so it's
like
what are we gonna do guys we're down one
game you know we're playing as eg
and so yeah we just came up with a strat
to get some momentum you know into the
game
so admiral bulldog intentionally
suicided to convince
eg that no tidehunter were attempting to
pull off a level one roche
the trap was set eg fell for the bait
and checked the roche pit where no tight
hunter slaughtered them
wow admiral bulldog given a freebie and
here we go
game is on the bait is lame
there's a small blood patch where
admiral [ __ ]
and it is it's actually a trap because
they came to check for it
now they're stunned it goes out of mouth
they're gonna bring it down
oh my james now all the penis
the swedes they pull something out of
the bag and feeders gonna go down as
well
oh no tide hunter what a start what a
strategy coming out from eternal envy
they snowballed their lead into a
victory and then carried that momentum
into
another win to take the trophy and
secure the roshan bait's place in the
history books
his ideas are always welcome the
smartest one amongst us the
god of dota next up at number nine we
have the fanatic
death brush death brush the classic here
is balance pulled back in it's going to
go
down flinch for a little while longer
the cat finally collects it
there was a time when fnatic were very
famous for a particular tactic in league
of legends
standing in a brush and waiting for the
enemy to get a little bit too
close doublelift walking right into the
bush he will face check this and he
could be going down he is absolutely
going down
the first hill to come out before a
minute of the game and fnatic starts
this one off
seasons came and went but for fnatic
the death brush was always in meta here
they go from the sidewalks to jump in
looking for pallet that thresh
still very tanky though is they not
fanatic back young generation perhaps
one that re-engaged now as ren goes to
the front line a child from jazz is a
five-man
child the knock-up [ __ ] still alive and
he's gonna pound away on caps red dead
two
dead from young generation fnatic able
to collapse able to get the fight they
wanted
this bait seems to be ingrained into the
very
dna of fnatic who kept doing it for
years even after the players who
innovated the bait
left the team and rocket it's not an
all-in fight yet
oh that would happen through what did
and now the depth charge is coming yard
takes a lot so as flashing forward
the moment of poor positioning
bursting into number eight we have the
burst bait
actually what you're seeing from debbie
is actually doing a high air dash he's
not doing an instant ear dash
and what that means is that the jump h
the hitbox on the bottom part of it is
actually clipping
the marlin pie out of his hover dash
yeah and so it's working out
and dividends right now
what do you do he beated it out still
hard as fake
many anime fighters like guilty gear and
dragon ball fighters
feature a burst mechanic that lets you
break out of a combo or
push the opponent away from you while
you're blocking their attacks
bursts are powerful and expensive
you rarely get more than one around but
even this
counter move has a counter a burst
bait if you can trick your opponent into
bursting
avoid it and then punish them you look
like a
god
[Music]
[Applause]
beating down on someone is one thing but
denying them their
one moment to fight back that's a hard
ass
bait there we go revenge assault
once again the first of all
at number seven we have a legendary
xpeke clip
he's trying to take the nexus down no
not that one
for this one we're going back to 2014 to
the eu lcs summer semi-final showdown
between fnatic and rockatt fnatic had
lost game one but came back
strong in game two the actors died
[Music]
with the game in their favor fnatic set
their eyes on
baron but they were worried about
getting collapsed on
so fnatic decided to fake starting the
baron
ex-pekke threw syndra balls as a decoy
while the rest of fnatic
waited to pounce
[Applause]
that was sensational stuff honestly from
becca
tricking them into it reminiscent of the
clairvoyance level one brush trick that
we saw from fnatic all those years ago
by now
at number six we have metsy faking out
not one but
two players in rocket league trying to
find his way through mata norris has a
break here oh what a big
mess that's enormous play
wedom girls were leading the series
versus chiefs esports club and
metsanaris was
on fire still really no threat of an
offense at all a light shot goes in from
metsanaris
but his best was yet to come this one is
crazy so let me explain it to you it's
game two
i ignite can't get a good shot off but
lays the ball back
in front of goal for metsy then instead
of rushing it down
metsy slams his brakes on and baits one
opponent and then
another into diving for a save to set up
the
easiest tap in rolling against the back
wall incoming tripping
drip a over one off the ceiling but he's
gonna have to pull away trippy and now
trying to find his way through metanars
has a break here oh what a big
mess what happens when you send your
opponents looking in the wrong
place you get and number five entry
faking
bomb sites we have been duped
get played suckers in games like cs go
and siege
controlling the bomb site is essential
but
sometimes all it takes to trick even the
smartest player
is a well-placed smoke grenade that's
actually a really nice smoke
that's gonna be a little bit nuts for
them they're going to be giving that
call this most wars b
and he's going to be going back towards
palace and you can see that's actually
working look at the scenes he's peeling
away now
hazy's fall better over he knows what
he's doing and there it is that kill
from kerrigan really makes this
interesting now
and sometimes teams really fall for the
bait
watch as immortal siege team tries to
plant the diffuser
three times because liquid baited the
hell out of them
[Music]
yes
siege actually has plenty of creative
ways to fake bomb sites
once team sinister actually managed to
bait the pittsburgh knights onto the
wrong
site by reinforcing sites across the map
let's see how this round pans out how
are you feeling they think it's bottom i
he even had me thinking it was bottom
yeah i'm pretty sure
sinister given from sinister and
pittsburgh think they're exploding on
the side but it's anything
else it's an absolute bloody onslaught
there
i wish we could hear knights comes right
now man because i feel like they would
be
like oh we've got sight now and then
they'll be like wait what
it's not down here oh that is hilarious
that's possibly the world's best
switching bait and the fact that
pittsburgh had gone all in so early in
the round as well it couldn't have
worked any better
at number four we're going to the
international 2019
to witness the true power of techies
[Applause]
in group b og faced off against vichy
gaming
and nobody seemed to be paying too much
attention to jerax
as he stacked techy's minds in the top
lane i don't think
they should remove tickets from i don't
think so either i think he's a funny
hero
look at this he's really funny hero you
know not long after eg lost a fight and
began to retreat
no tell hobbled back down lane and it
looked like it was
all over for him and it might have been
if it wasn't for those minds
get into the mind seriously please no
jerick save us anything but
vichy gaming have no rewards of mine
[Applause]
oh gee they got wiped but at least they
brought
vg gang down with them what a babe
[Music]
and number three is coming in with a
bang or
is it it's fake flashes in csgo
there's not many things sweeter than
baiting the enemy into thinking they're
about to get
flashed you can cancel the pin pulling
mid animation
this isn't going to go well no this
crossfire is pretty good
who would you be keeping an eye on here
obviously you always watch the tv
or you can fling a pistol into the air
and by the time they realize
it's not a grenade it's far too late
all of you at home are probably hating
me right now oh what the [ __ ]
or you can just go full blown simple and
chuck
an actual orb in the air if you feel
like it
it might be pricey but it gets the job
done outside smoke gonna go off simple
on the other side it pulls out the
pistol he's got the p250
close range it's a one-shot nitro he's
got a triple he fakes it once and just
goes to check the window this is all
about timing nitro does have a bottle of
another smoke so it could be really
rough or simple to actually get
through this he's gonna throw the awp oh
my god simple what is happening
[Applause]
what if it is that at number two we have
an entry that is only a few letters away
from getting this video
demonetized the cast of bait
i i knew better dude during smash the
record 2017
commentators ee and dc took some time
out between games to read out donations
but ee wasn't checking the donator names
as carefully as he should have been
foreskin tim he donated ten dollars he
said shout out to all my young samus
so thank you tim we appreciate that
i'll read that i i knew better dude
dc however didn't stay on his high horse
for too long
soon it was his turn to take the bait
you fell for the oldest streak in the
book
that's the one donation from jenna tools
oh no no no you just did it
and finally at number one your eyes do
not deceive you
it's the idra gg wouldn't it be funny if
you hallucinated a bunch of carriers and
your opponent just left
that is what we just saw here at mlg
back at mlg dallas 2011 idra and huck
were
neck and neck but right before hawk went
on the assault
he decided to warp in some hallucination
void rays
the crowd held their breath surely
a seasoned vet like idra would see
through this mirage
those hallucinated void rays almost
fully charged wheat
and idra left the game
oh oh my
goodness idra but idra
took the bait he thought they were real
and
rage quit out of a very winnable game
huck had some questions at the start of
their next game but
let's just say idra wasn't really in the
mood to answer them
so huck can't win in a real game huh
pretty much you wouldn't win at all if
you didn't play projects
stand by your guns on that one all right
guys there you go
i hope you enjoyed those baits and now
in the comment section i want to hear
from you
about what was the worst time you ever
got baited in a game
like absolutely straight updated i
promise if you guys share your worst
most embarrassing stories i will share
mine with you
i was a silver ranked player in league
of legends
it was very embarrassing i'm not going
to say any more on the matter until i
hear from you guys though
i think that's fair i remember a story
going around when i was quite young
that the one of the original pokemon
games
had to be recalled when they like first
made it in english
because they had named the different
types of fishing bait
in the same way they named like
pokeballs so
it went like normal baits and then like
a great bait and then
ultrabait and if you know where this is
going
you know where this is going i'm not
going to say any more